[Music]
all righty ladies and gentlemen welcome
to the creek in the game
just a couple things before we get
started you guys say you keep table talk
to a minimum cell phones
[Music]
[Applause]
what is up austin texas it's good to be
here
getting dates and watching people [ __ ]
uh my name is hans kim i'm a kill tony
regular and an
asian
man
uh we're gonna have a great time today
uh we got a guest very funny comedian
from austin she also has a van that she
travels and tours in please go to a very
funny ariel isaac norman
[Applause]
hello ariel hey thanks for having me
thanks for coming to this dating show
we're going to watch people date have
you caught have you ever watched people
date before
uh
you mean like at a restaurant where
you're watching them or yeah like in a
weird way
uh no i feel like i want to though it's
an option i'm not against watching
people i'm very into the idea uh
so i've been to sex parties before
nice
yeah so it's like the end result of
dating
yeah i guess so but the people at these
sex parties are not always as hot as
you'd want them to be so
yeah sex parties it sounds like
if you're willing to have sex in front
of people
it's probably not your
first option it's like oh i have to have
sex in front of people to have sex
i would i would think you would think
hot people would be the ones having sex
in front of you people are the worst
yeah they're never having sex in front
of you like you want them to yeah
they're always with their clothes on
just hanging out like a bunch of waste
there's always the uglies that are naked
and
fleeing jizz everywhere
in my experience at these sex maybe i'm
going to the wrong sex parties
well tonight is going to be one heck of
a sex party uh if you haven't signed up
yet please sign up we need the more the
merrier we have no lgbtqia plus so
do you just do any any queer people date
any other queer people in that bucket
doesn't lesbians gays who
i'm cares kidding it's pride week
we uh we're very supportive so please
sign up
uh we will support you
we'll help you come out to your parents
et cetera et cetera there's a whole girl
in the bucket so one chick
does she have to date everybody yeah
she has to be the sex party
uh
[Music]
mvp
this is
ed allen alan j allen
h.j allen hand job allen
there we go hj allen thanks for hand job
alan
going on a date with lorena
they came
oh
together
of the few people that signed up please
sign up the buckets are right here if
you don't we're going to pick people at
random
does this mean that we could maybe ruin
their relationship tonight
one minute of dating and then we
interview you one minute starting now
let's watch them date
hey there how are you
i'm fine
okay got a lot to work with yep
letting you leave for once
lead uh let's see are you from austin i
am cool i'm not
where are you from i'm from tennessee
that's why i'm the only 10 you see yeah
it's pretty good it's pretty good
um so what
jay allen do you have a big dick or what
well yeah you
it's like a trick question that you
already knew the answer to
what's setting you up yeah i do yeah
it's no hans kim dick but it's a big
dick
um cool
what do you like to do
let's see i uh
big baseball fan so i'm missing the
braves play right now so i can be here
do you think they should change the name
yeah right totally not cleveland
guardians atlanta cowards
yeah
i'd have to find a new team if they did
that i'd have to go to the st louis
cardinals until we found a reason for
the birds
give it up for lorena and alan
allen has such a big dick he doesn't
have enough blood to write properly jay
allen are you supposed to write for this
i think i i wrote it i wrote it oh you
wrote it guilty guilty it was a bad pen
you were getting [ __ ] so hard by this
giant [ __ ] you couldn't write properly
yeah i have not been so lucky what is
this supposed to say jay allen j allen
okay
there's just an extra j that failed and
tried again
that's a good good spirit my mom's
my mom also criticizes me for my
handwriting so thank you and you're the
top in this relationship it seems no
we're just friends oh oh so this is a
legit date
how do you how did it go to you
wait did you guys but she already you
already know how big his dick is right
so that's how good our friends are i was
a little drunk one night and i sent her
a video of me getting my dick sucked
with his ex beyonce
is that okay is that normal friend
behavior i don't know i've heard of
who's elizabeth oh i don't know what's
your name my name's ariel i'm so sorry
that's okay mermaid got it
how do you know his girlfriend or how do
you know his ex-fiance wasn't just
really small and it made his dick look
way bigger it's a great show she
actually did have small heads so it's
funny and she was my ex-fiance in the
video that i sent so did you see this
video too i said it jay allen going on
dates with children
yeah
it might be a crime to send that
video i think that's actually illegal no
i wasn't mad when i did it if what did
you have
you should be like upset would you do it
no did you have your ex's permission
yeah of course revenge
only counts if you're angry if you're
angry you're like i'm sorry i was just
really drunk i was like i'm gonna send
this tape to lorena a good friend of
mine yeah no reason she was like okay
yeah i'm a child i don't know anything
who is your ex-fiancee what happened to
this
engagement
such a good story come on give them the
details
there's no story just didn't work okay
so
lorena's gonna spill the secrets live on
youtube.com
[Laughter]
oh is this live this is live yeah
you just worship my [ __ ] for the
internet i hope your ex really knows
what you're up to because
this is on tv now yeah yeah yeah
yeah she knows so uh how did you meet
your ex-fiance
at a bar
at a bar
you had that mustache
that careless look on your face no the
mustache is new
oh you're fresh shaven
probably like a little boy yeah has
dating gotten better since you got the
mustache
it's about the same
still non-existent still not yeah okay
putting a dressing on a
pig won't make it i'm just kidding
you're a very handsome man oh thank you
sir surprise that you have a big [ __ ]
when you get a boner that could not be
true though too that's
just well how big is it
well it's i don't want to like give you
what
do you really want i want to know how
big everyone's dick is this is 20 22.
this is a sex crime you can't
can't ask a man how big his dick is
how big is your dick false modesty if
someone asks you directly and you don't
say it how big is your dick solid eight
and a half eight and a half holy [ __ ]
now how big is your
they can vagina
great
maybe you guys should date i don't know
your questions weren't getting anywhere
all you you talked about
i knew too much i knew
you know you what i knew too much yeah
you already know each other your fly's
kind of down oh no
thank you
ariel embarrassing what's the biggest
thing you've had in your vagina
a wrapper's stick
a what a wrapper stick a rapper's dick
is this really live on youtube i'll say
it what was his race
who's black is petey pablo
petey publicly famous
take your shirt off
and wave it around a little long term
okay we gotta speaks for itself
i know we got a bunch of soundcloud fans
tonight how big was his dick uh bigger
than that i'm certain yeah damn yeah so
your dick is probably nothing
you're a white eight and a half that's
way different from a black eight and a
half yeah
exactly
it's like a pipe you know girth matters
yeah girth lives matter so uh
i've got the old pencil light and a half
what can i say ugh
jay alves
what what's your dating uh strategy how
do you go out there and try to sow your
seed
well the last girl that i picked up was
at my dental office
so i don't know i just i just drugged
her up and had your way with her i feel
like that's brave
you ask out the receptionist
your dental office is in where you go or
where you work oh yeah no i work from
home uh it was just where i went to get
my dental work yeah for like my six
month checkup i was like i won't see her
for six months if she says no no big
deal so you picked her up how did it go
did she find any did you find any
cavities
uh yeah no i uh
took her out
that's about it you know came back to
the place did what we did did you try
your tennessee line on her that kind of
went over well
yeah no i think maybe she said that to
me that was uh she's from tennessee too
no she was like oh you're from tennessee
that's why you're the only ten i see so
i just kind of you guys have the same
[ __ ]
i stole yeah you stole her shitty line
same shitty sense of humor not that i
haven't ever heard that you know being
from tennessee i've heard that a time or
two
yeah nashville more like asheville
everyone's
it's [ __ ] each other
so you guys are never gonna date each
other
how was his [ __ ] in the video did
were you impressed
oh big
[Music]
he was [ __ ] her mouth i think is what
hans was going for right oh yeah yeah
yeah
how was that that's fine
can you give us the details no he
he
we got this sir he was like
that's all you have to say and i was
like sorry
um no i mean it was fine they were both
clothed which i feel like is not a good
video when you've got [ __ ] to do you got
to like get the blood job and i just
think like sex what did they do through
their jeans and you have your clothes
you put his fly down much like you had
your flight out tonight yeah yeah
i have way too many [ __ ] videos where
my pants are on and my dick's just like
through the a.m
why do you why do you do you prefer it
that way i'm just usually busy
he's a busy man i've got stuff to do
you're busy waiting for you to pull down
your pants right basically yeah
one of my videos is from work so i got
like khakis on and
dress clothes and like you know somebody
might come through the door you know
you have a office job that's the most
surprising thing i've heard yeah i don't
know i'd assume you worked outside you
got a nice tan going yeah i got a pool
at the apartment did you say you work
from home i do but you're too busy to
pull down your pants well i haven't
always worked from home
these days i have nothing going on so
yeah okay
you're never wearing pants in the first
place basically yeah yeah no shirt just
shorts so you don't have a job and you
can make all the sex videos you want but
you're you're not getting it
i'm not getting anything back in the day
when you had a normal job that's when i
could meet people yeah this work from
home life sucks so you were [ __ ]
people at your work isn't that a big
no-no yeah probably oh my gosh
you're [ __ ] [ __ ] what you eat i
wasn't [ __ ] the staff i was just
bringing people to the office like look
where i work i have a job
yeah [ __ ]
doors or anyone could walk in like well
an adult with a job yeah it impresses me
as a child
that's what i got the jurassic park
sleeve for bro like to lure them in nice
to bri real the children in
yeah tattoo children love tattoos
lorena yeah what's your dating history
like
it's um
checkered um
is that where you pick up uh
yeah
yeah i go to i go to um
outdoor chess competitions okay no i
don't know i haven't dated anyone long
term i'm in a
um
horror no i mean i've been a side chick
for five years
so
committed before
to whom
a guy petey pablo
like a married man
a married man no no i think right if
it's it's not engaged or married right
it doesn't
i don't know i don't know i feel like
yeah exactly i feel like there's
gradations to infidelity but
that's just how i get myself to go to
sleep at night
for five years though i know it's so
long
do you want more from him or do you
happy with this um i was happy with it
without for a long time
and then actually
yesterday i told him i i was like i'm
not giving an ultimatum however
if you left her
we could be in an open relationship
yeah and um yeah it went well it was
fine so is he maybe going to leave her
maybe
i i i'm a typical side chick i'm aware
i'm aware i always i i hate being
predictable so i always was like i don't
want him to leave her for me
you know because like that's pretty
predictable to pretend you're okay with
it exactly
yeah um but i never was under any
illusions he did break up with her that
they did get back together
oh
if he broke up with her and right back
yeah it's over dude
but now you're here dating people on
this game show oh no yeah here i am
hopefully that will help
have you ever tried asking for a sex
video between
your boyfriend slash whatever
you know there's not a word for what he
is other than like scumbag have you ever
asked for a sex tape much like
jay allen oh yeah we we film all the
time but ours is hot
no have you ever asked for a sex tape
from him and his girl oh no no i would
never i pretend she doesn't exist
that's awesome yeah
so that's uh that's interesting
um
jay allen what do you think about uh
being in an open relationship would you
be down for that
yeah if she was into women and she was
only wanting to be open with me and
women i would totally be down so you
want a sex slave
the best porn videos are the ones with
like a guy and like two or three other
girls the devil's threesome doesn't
interest him yeah
two guys you don't want to [ __ ] a chick
together with a one of your best friends
not my girl like some random girl cool
but
not the girl that i love
oh yeah did you just
quote me
well you haven't seen this this is why i
don't date men i'm either i think most
guys have eiffel tower but not with my
girlfriend you haven't dated in a while
you got to take what you can get that's
two guys
oh instead of
oh okay that's where the eiffel tower
comes in architecturally this guy spends
all day on urban dictionary
um so yeah i mean what uh what's the
craziest sexual position that you've
been in
driving down the road the girl on top of
me that was pretty wild because i live
in like a i'm from like a backwoods
tennessee so it's curvy ash cousin she's
like
she's got her curves in your face and
curves on the road there's curves all
over the place well you know just like
looking over her shoulder trying to tend
to drive while she's riding me i can't
see
basically pull it through out pull it
pull my dick out through the khakis
well you know i had to keep my pants on
if i'm driving so that's better yeah
that's your thing
you don't like to be naked
he said never
it just seems like she's going to be
hurting herself on the zipper or
something or you're hurting yourself
yeah you're hurting yeah i'm like you
know there's a little [ __ ] action too
going on there the zipper top the zipper
on the clip oh no zippers backwards so i
guess that'd be butthole i don't know if
that's a good idea zipper on the [ __ ]
yeah
no
yeah
on the [ __ ]
did she get all eight and a half inches
in there while you were driving
ah presumptuously yeah
presumptuously she got
confused like tennessee vocabulary
presumptuously you know it's like
assuming with some uh fact behind it
presumably
presumptuously yeah okay presumptuously
other verses
i'm beginning to doubt this eight and a
half figure
you don't think a big dick goes along
with a poor vocabulary
[Laughter]
coasting
mm-hmm
yeah yeah your one question for her was
are you from austin and i knew the
answer already yeah
why didn't you just ask her something
about her hopes and dreams or something
i was i was honestly just trying to give
a real example of how shitty i am at
trying to pick up a girl that's like
some dumb [ __ ] i'd say her hope is to
not date you
and to date the person she's been
sidetricking for
yeah see like from his english it's a
great relationship
so what do you think you could say to
this guy to finally make him leave his
girl
i don't know
like i have a
i don't know like
i can get completely naked for you
that would work for jay allen oh you
mean to to uh
wait
because he doesn't like to get naked at
all right and your fly was down which is
basically a come on to him
right
yeah
give it up for lorena and jay allen
they're friends they're not gonna [ __ ]
we got two whole girls in here
and a lot a lot of dudes some of you
guys are gonna have to date each other
we got scott sauder coming up
and monica
do they know each other
are they from the same table
please yeah hopefully they're different
i just learned that monica you're not
you it's a dangerous name to say because
it's not you could be saying a racial
slur
you could be yep did you know that oh
[ __ ] i'm not how's that how's that going
for you my [ __ ] yeah yeah whoa
what was her name it was her name
it's just how you pronounce my name no
that is not how you pronounce your name
monica
of all the people that say the n n-word
i didn't think it'd be you i thought
it'd be this guy
i'm sorry
we're gonna go on a minute of dating
with
the guy in the proud boys shirt with the
girl who says n-word
and
it's in her name to be fair go
um
hi hi how are you good what was your
name my name's scott scott scott where
are you from i'm from pittsburgh
pennsylvania originally
far far away from home how about you uh
i'm from dallas dallas yeah okay yeah
are you uh you in austin now are you
just here for the show no i'm
lived here for three years now so yeah
what's the worst date you've ever been
on
um oh i uh i had sex with a homeless
person but i didn't know he was homeless
at the time oh
wow
that's how was that what did he smell
bad or did they smell bad see they don't
smell as bad outside but once you let
them in
that's where yeah he smoked then
wow okay
what do you like to do for fun
mostly comedy stuff how about how about
you
uh it's a good
i i don't know i like to uh
i don't know like to work out i like and
time
thank you thank you for monica she likes
to work out
i like how that's she's a exercise fiend
not really
were you lying no that's just like the
only thing that came to my mind like
when he asked me that you asked him
first you should i know but i'm good at
asking questions i'm not you were trying
to control the conversation so it never
came back to you you can dish it out but
you can't take it
now how come scott wasn't in the lgbtq
bucket
so i wasn't sure which one to choose oh
um
i didn't i cause i do like to date women
too so
i was like oh okay you were like let's
put my name in the bucket that has the
least chance of me getting laid tonight
[Applause]
he's a hero
yeah
um playing the game on difficulty
setting
hard
i'm like your dick tonight
so yeah when you let the
man into your home and then he smelled
bad you still had sex with him
i was a little thirsty
um
and
[Applause]
i will say he did use like a alcohol pad
on the
down there before he sterilized his [ __ ]
yes sir oh my god
is alcohol okay to just put i mean i
guess you maybe you just got a little
drunk when he [ __ ] you in the did you
put that in your butt and then you
yeah yeah so
um
yeah a little a little discomfort there
but yeah
um we use the condom so i mean it's kind
of like good choice maybe a little one
that could
he didn't want to get the condom dirty
no
i didn't know people were yeah swabbing
their dicks with alcohol have you ever
heard of that no i've never heard of
that that's a homeless people trick
[Laughter]
it's like in those little packs they
give them with shampoo and a comb
there's like a alcohol pad i didn't know
that's what pad was for yeah
yeah famously that's how you defeat
gonorrhea as
poor alcohol on your dick don't use them
on your [ __ ] if you're a homeless woman
out there i don't think that's gonna go
well
i i pretty sure you're gonna get an
infection i guess the dick is fine
though this guy's never seen a [ __ ]
before yeah it's called ph sir yeah
uh but
[Music]
scott solder what do what would you say
your ratio is from male to female or
male and female um
well when i was younger before i came
out it was like all women boring yeah so
probably right now it's like 50 50. yeah
yeah it's pretty much equal opportunity
and uh monica
what's your ratio
strictly dick baby
all the dudes went crazy
yeah finally i think that was a black
dude who said he was upset earlier too
he's changed his mind
nice
that's the thing about men if you
suck their dick leaves yeah everything
else is forgiven
have you hooked up with black dudes
my like first little boyfriend was a
little boyfriend yeah it was like
another pedophile middle school he was
yes he's a black guy you guys were both
little yeah we were did you call him the
n word was it like
a call me by your name situation
[Music]
did you did uh did he call you that yep
just kidding
monica
that's yeah
no he didn't
what are you racially what am i um i'm
mexican
and white
so
not
one of the people that can say the
n-word no
mexicans used to be able to when i was
growing up in the 90s yeah the 90s yeah
are we we're done with that now
9 11 happened
my bad yeah i was at 9 11. okay i didn't
mean to come like guns ablaze in and
like say that but you said it and i
people have called me that before like
when they're saying my name they just
say it slower and
it sounds like what it sounds
yeah i'm never gonna i'm never gonna say
that name ever again
you also you know what other word you
can't say anymore let's hear it vinegar
vinegar yeah because if you cut out the
vi that's worse than monica monica's a
soft r
yep
learning saying racial slurs with monica
and scott no
i don't want that to be what how many
times how many times a week do you
usually don't i don't
i'm a lover of people
but
these are just things that
i've noticed
in life
she gets to say it she's a minority
scott what's the most racist thing that
you've done
[Applause]
um i i guess like
moved into riverside and jacked up the
rent
you gays are always ruining black
neighborhoods
what'd you do to start a cupcake shop in
this case
um
no it's i started a small uh
smile what have you brought why did you
bring a whole oh i'm sorry i didn't you
got a handheld ipad i wanted to put it
under i went i just didn't want to leave
it like in there you don't trust the
audience to not steal your ipad
wow wow
you're not dating a dude you can't just
bring weird [ __ ] on a date and have them
ignore it girls
girls are way more discerning
what do you think about scott bringing
an ipad on a date i mean when he put it
on the table i was like why does he have
that
but i didn't mean to
do you use your ipad while you're
rollerblading to your next dick
[Laughter]
[Music]
i um i was uh filming some content
earlier that's why i have it with your
clothes on or off
oh um halfway on halfway off which uh
winnie the pooh or which version
um
yeah for the just the top top half
though the chrysler
thing yeah the boring half
yeah
yeah yeah i don't you don't even look
like you'd have good pecs this sucks can
i take my shirt off well yes please
turn around let him see the bat
[Music]
i don't know i think some good pec
injections would be good though it's
like almost there
thank you yeah i have been thinking
about getting a little work done like
here we go my nose is really crooked
it's been broken a couple times
no the nose isn't the problem it's
okay i don't want the pecs i want the
pecs filled out
maybe trim a little the top hairs i
think she's trying to give you boobs
yeah pecs i don't know
i'm i'm really self-conscious now i want
to put my shirt back on you're looking
it's also freezing up here you look like
a lot of the lesbians in austin yeah
that's a compliment in their community
[Laughter]
look like a trader joe's lesbian at this
point
[Laughter]
[Music]
i guess scott doesn't share your hobby
of working out
that's okay i don't really work out
either like i said that was a lie that
was a lie
what were you thinking when you said you
like working what do people like to do
work out
not say the n word
yeah that too
so what do you like to do for fun
dude i like to be boring i like to do
home improvement projects that's my
thing you are mexican yeah
yep what was the latest home improvement
project uh today i helped my neighbor uh
clear off his deck and uh landscaping no
his lawn yeah oh that sounds classic
sounds like an only fan subscription
with scotland
uh no he wasn't but i saw maybe he was
would you would you go on another date
with scott
no
oh
nothing personal she's homophobic
because he's too gay
he does seem quite gay i mean if you're
if you're gay enough to suck a homeless
guy's dick then that's pretty gay yeah
to be
[Music]
i'm definitely not straight so
i understand if you prefer men who are
we'll call it that she says
why were you so thirsty when you were
with the homeless man
um i i just moved into like my first
apartment here in austin so i'd kind of
like been you know just car life in it
so i didn't really have the opportunity
so you were homeless right before
oh that's why you're not judgmental
you're like i just got a house come in
come in
you were showing off your wealth
and how did you meet this homeless man
um
he was at the buzz mill
like uh
they used to have bonfires at the buzz
mill they don't do that anymore i think
but you used to be able to meet cool
yeah everyone was getting aids
did you did you let him take a shower
after
yeah why didn't you have him you have a
shower before
instead of the alcohol swab you had
access to a shower he could have used
i know i might have been [ __ ] up a
little bit you know it's just kind of in
a hurry to get busy i guess
nice i'll do better next time let's get
busy
stick that dirty [ __ ] in me
what's up
is that spanish is he winning
yeah i i have that tattooed oh
in spanish
yeah it means give it to me yeah
why did you get that tattooed
was that the homeless died with that to
you
no this um this is in high school and
i was actually dating a woman then but
weird yeah
um
i think we we both took we met in
spanish class so it's like a high school
you're like i want to be really popular
at taco bell
um
so
that's cool you uh
what was going on he's
gay he has a give it to me tattoo and
that you got in high school that's isn't
it did you have to get your parents
permission to get damilo
tattooed um i i was i was late i was 18
my full my
so this is how i feel when i see someone
with an asian tattoo
oh it's like you're appropriating my
culture
i'm gonna get a chinese tattoo next
really is that okay with you yeah thanks
you got the c
you got the zero of approval
monaco what do you think about white
dudes are they all sort of gay
yes
well welcome to austin
this is what we have
who have you dated in austin who was
your i've been with the same guy for
four years oh you're in a relationship
sorry boring
it's not the last guy was it
no
it wasn't no he's
he's a white guy yeah yeah what's the
race of the person you're dating white
oh okay this is austin she doesn't have
a lot of options
what does he have tattooed on his body
he's got a lot of tattoos
but uh
yeah i don't know he's got several you
don't remember he's got hello kitty on
his butt
that's cute wow what a quirky dude
is that racist
are you okay
that is a people's uh
o.j simpson
hello kitty is asian o.j simpson yeah
what did hello kitty do
he uh
bombed pearl harbor oh okay
so you have been in austin three years
yeah and you've been with this guy four
years
yes where did you guys meet dallas
on bumble
oh
yeah
yeah yeah the worst place to bumble
where do you live 40 miles away
everything's so far there yeah it is
so uh your couple kids from dallas
couple kids from dallas
did you like his tattoos
no you didn't you're like mike some kind
of abuela would have disapproved right
but he has some good tattoos too
it balances out it balances out is he
oh that's him
ask me later
oh you all haven't ever talked about it
is he in the bucket to go on a date too
i don't know are y'all opening it up
here
no we're we're just
yeah yep
so this is adding a new flavor you get
your ears it's stale i'm just kidding
so you're just getting your kicks
through fake dates that's right that's
cute with gay dudes
wouldn't you be okay with her dating gay
dudes in general
not yeah
yeah you could i'm just saying you could
you could do this on other nights
probably all right good to know
good to know there's a boundary
so how is dating a girl different from
dating a dude
what's the what's one of the things that
you notice that's different well um i
didn't believe yes
uh i didn't believe toxic masculinity
was a thing until i started dating guys
so you got toxic shock syndrome from
[ __ ] homeless dudes
um but no i guess the biggest difference
is like
i like to be
the woman in the relationship with men
and i like to be the man in the
relationship with what does that mean to
you
uh i guess i'd be more of a bottom when
i'm in a gay room that's what you mean
by being the woman
oh who's getting [ __ ] i've said the
women famously
have no [ __ ]
i have several so
oh [ __ ]
but they've never been packed you like
being you like being the top with women
and the bottom with men yes okay
what about a really small man
that's a good question oh oh yeah so
actually yeah people that are like i'm
you know i'm not a big guy so people but
every once in a while i'll meet someone
smaller than me and then yeah i would be
the top so you just are going strictly
by size
if the woman was bigger would she also
yeah i get to peg you that kind of a
giant woman or a small man which one
would you choose yeah
i i've never had a giant woman i'm gonna
go with the giant woman
yeah
do we have any giant women here tonight
preferably homeless
yeah we want to hear what you do with
your vagina
so uh
yeah you guys uh
aren't gonna go on another date but if
you were to
what would you do and who would touch
you first
well how tall is she
i'm 4 10. oh
yeah
um we could go to the beach so that this
shirt could get
like some
some light of day i would enjoy that
it's a beachy shirt and that way you'd
have a new hobby going to the beach
that's right i don't have hobbies but
yep we could go to the beach
long walks on beaches
love dogs
with small dogs oh i i must love dogs
i do i do love dogs
oh now they're hitting it off
what do you call your dogs
what
the n-word no
they're all named monica so she
that's my loophole yeah
well give it up for scott and monica
[Applause]
we got some more women we even got a
whole
lgbtqia i hope you're asexual because
there's one there's only one of you
we got paige wilson coming up
and pedro what's his name valenzuela
venezuela
pedro
pedro and paige that's cute
[Applause]
paige here she comes
from oh no that's she's just going to
the bottom page decide not to shut up
pedro participate okay paige
paige is not coming
we got liz
bars coming up
do we have another one back can we put
page back in just in case it was just
because of pedro that she didn't know
she's brian
paige pedro you got up here way too
early
yeah you gotta trick him like you're in
the bushes
liz bars
this is not coming i'll take a guy we
can do a guy should we do a guy
sure
at this point
let's burn up two guys together
k-i-o-u-s
serie guy caius cayose kaios
is this a real name no dudes
all right i'll just i'll just date
myself pedro no one wants to date you
pretty used to it uh
all right you're coming
is this monica's
is this monica's boyfriend
you're just another white dude with
shitty tattoos
does he have tattoos
go to the right there's stairs right
there
i wonder how he spilled his beer
he met scott earlier
give it up for
uh
and pedro
hello what's up what's up kaios how you
doing
pretty terrible i'm not gonna lie i just
got rejected by two women in a row
and uh
you're not really my type either so
that's
he's a professional
and that failed i think
okay
now you know he's a professional
so uh wait did the date start
okay
so what do you do for work
chaos i run um
i i run a non-profit run a non-profit at
school
it's actually uh [ __ ] you know like a
good thing moral thing to do
it is do you want to know what it is
not really what do you think i do for
work
now i'm sad
i'm just kidding
i think i've seen you with a squeegee
trying to wash my windows on 35.
well uh that's if that's fair is that it
is that in play or no
and time give
and pedro let's get it i hope that you
don't work in a homeless outreach
nonprofit because
that's right i buy i buy a lot of
overpriced [ __ ] from
whatever the china
yep
yeah yeah yeah he was afraid to say
china
with that it's okay it is a country it's
not a racial slur
unless you use it as one
it's an
option so what is your non-profit
uh i help
transgendered
pets
find their identity oh so he's lying
okay wow he's a trump supporter
he runs a super pac for ron desantis
a gender pet therapist though i wish
that were a real thing that's
sounds pretty it sounds pretty cool yeah
have you ever questioned your gender
absolutely which gender would you be
like uh i heard this like a worm kin
yeah you can be anything you want to be
a worm person
you want to be a worm
what why the [ __ ] not
i gotta wear them let's keep it it's
just identifying worms don't even have a
gender bro
you're basically identifying as a dude
he's a professional
what you're basically you're like i i
have a worm i am does anybody feel like
this guy doesn't like me either
i would what is happening
so what uh what do you think about
transgender
women in women's sports
uh i think leah thomas is super hot
and i like because i
yeah what you just like yourself
yeah i look at myself in the mirror
every morning and i'm like i would [ __ ]
me
you're like i'd [ __ ] me so hard you're
like i look like an ncaa woman swimming
champion [ __ ] yeah
i would watch you [ __ ] yourself hell
yeah let's get it let's get it girl i
think that's already happening
i'd watch you
[ __ ] him he's a professional
are you saying that he sucks dick for
money
i'm saying that most comedians
definitely suck day for coke so you've
seen pedro on stage before
i think so
just because but i only remember him
because he's a beautiful man
that actually did help a little bit to
hit home with you
yeah that made me feel a little better
i'm not gonna lie
you just came up here and you were
disrespectful right off the bat and like
you do look a little homeless to be
honest that's what that's what check's
like
oh he was nagging you i'm just i was
nagging it's the negging to pegging
are you uh flattered
not really i kind of hate this guy to be
honest i don't
i don't know what it is i just kind of
want to hit you in the face but i'm not
going to
everyone here hates him as well
that's not a surprise
what's the whitest thing that you've
done this year
oh [ __ ]
oh man i'm not prepared for that um
the white i shop at whole foods did you
call your dad
yeah yeah it was his birth
it was his birthday it was white as [ __ ]
it was very white because i have a i
have a dad right here that's why it's
working what do you call your dad
that was so like i call him bad if i
have
the way you said i have a dad and then
kind of glanced over at me i was as if i
didn't have a father
but that's okay dude pedro do you have a
subconscious gesture
is your father in your life
uh he's
kind of he lives
he lives in florida so he's far away but
you know he's stuck around most of the
time
my dad's in florida
when was the last time that you talked
to your dad
what i want to know is why no one asked
me what i do for work no one cares you
guys just
he's the [ __ ] meat guy at chipotle
that you're like you're like bro
hook it up he's the guy that won't wear
the hair now
okay pedro when was the last time you
talked to your dad
uh
i talked to him a few weeks ago he told
me be weary of douchebags
at shows that
i don't even know he's never seen his
dad before
[Music]
you shall be named after the great roman
empire
caius
the second your name is hans
yeah i i don't i don't know where do we
go where do we go with that i know we're
both german
oh you're german we have a we have that
in common yeah where were your parents
between the years of 1939 and 1942 you
know exactly where they were
and we're not going to talk about that
they're regarding the parapets
watching for
little pedros and aerial isaac normans
so this guy is very german that's that's
kind of cool
um
what do you do that's german do you eat
sausages
i do i eat a lot of sausage homeless
sausages i'd want you to eat a sausage
what kind what kind
homeless
what i'm homeless a homeless sausage
alcohol swabs like made out of homeless
people no like their dick
dick thing it's a dick oh oh no like the
last dude
yeah no i envy him because i could never
suck a i could never soak a duck to
begin with but
i don't think
yeah [ __ ] yeah yeah no but that's uh i
feel like that's a realm that like i
it's dude are you secretly a fan of me
and you're not even telling me bro who
me what yeah
cause you're driving i don't know why
you aren't talking about how do you know
my porn preferences german sausage how
do you know that i actually feel like
doing shitty improv if i've never [ __ ]
a dude in my life i feel like i should
probably [ __ ] this you couldn't [ __ ] a
dude dude what is this what's up what's
up what's up baby this is the best of
days
so far yeah yeah now you're looking at
my phone now you yeah that's a thing i
don't have any text messages on there
i'm clear all right that's gonna have
[ __ ] going on let's get a checkup here
clear pedro
we're gonna get a checkup here thank you
for coming on i did
give it up for pedro
[Applause]
that was so rude that you said that he's
uh squeegeeing
squeegeeing your windows i don't want to
hate on you
liz bars she's very high
liz bars come on up and go on a date
with caius
is she too high
come on you can do it
see if the other woman are you guys from
the same table you know liz
what about
paige paige wilson you want to go on a
date with caius
look at it we're not we're not really
dating we're just sitting and talking
just like oh it's oh here we go here
comes paige round of applause for paige
nice try
she's coming up to date
with her boyfriend in the front row
and
date hello howdy hi
where are you from
new hampshire
it's unfortunate
have you ever been there
no
then how can you say it's unfortunate
sound i don't know it just sounds not
just guessing yeah okay what's the
furthest to the northeast you've ever
been
this is how my real dates go by the way
buffalo buffalo is uh it's a frigid
tundra [ __ ] of a
place they lost my luggage oh my god
and where were you going canada
well
that's just not a good thing no i know
you shouldn't have been going to canada
okay
so
my date's over yeah
he's down and
now i'm just gonna order like a like a
double whiskey do it
i can't because i'm on work
yeah yeah this is like uh if we were
married for like
40 years basically
i hate your that you're from new
hampshire yeah it just nothing nothing
nothing was good from the start has
anyone ever had anything positive to say
when you said that you're from new
hampshire absolutely not no okay there's
like no cities in that state
i mean we're not we're not we're not
going to name two cities from new
hampshire
what the capital of concord somebody
somebody that's why i said two
there's like yeah i can name all cities
well new hampshire is known for being
not known for anything
it is it flies under the radar and uh if
you want to move to a state like texas
that doesn't have
texas terrible weather
new hampshire is a place it's a it's a
texas of the northeast
it's a beautiful hampshire it's not
texas
please don't go there guys you got to
let other people talk
no you're not used to that because
you're on dates a lot
do you do you get laid a lot because
you're a very handsome man caius
do you want to go on a date
yes
well
maybe you could have more energy
next time you go on a date maybe sit up
straight
maybe not mumble
i don't fit in chairs bruh
how tall are you
i'm like i'm like six four how big is
your dick
it's not as big as
the gentlemen
[Music]
yeah i don't believe that for a [ __ ]
second you don't believe
no i don't believe that i think he's got
a five and a half skinny there's only
one way to find out
dick off i think he's got a skinny i
think he's got a skinny there's only one
that's what's up are you sure you're not
projecting
i'm not my dick my dick my dick's bomb
i'm telling you straight up it's bomb
i don't i know that's why i know that's
not what you want to hear but it's bomb
that's a good indicator yeah it's not a
monster
it's not scary what what is bomb to you
though
it's what do you say
don't encourage the hecklers
you're doubting that
this man has a big dick jay allen has a
big dick there's only one way to find
jay allen there's only one way to find
out you gotta put it in your mouth
put it in your mouth put it in your
mouth anybody remember that song
who's got an alcohol swab
who's who's who's swabbing homeless
people dicks though
is when i'm wondering very capable
paige wilson what do you think about
this guy
he's from new hampshire
how many people from new hampshire do
you know none
and this guy's not making a good
impression not making the cut
to say i know someone from new hampshire
do you think that maybe he could um you
know be like less douchey or
yeah
please don't hold back
i don't even know what to say
how did you meet your husband
the bar
oh everyone meets at the bar yeah that's
cool you didn't do the apps
what did he i was on the apps but what
did he say to you
[Music]
he just came up to me and asked me for
my number
oh my god that worked
that's so romantic he went for your
number before
getting to know you at all like he said
what's your number and i asked what his
name was but
to my
defense or his defense i guess his my
best friend and his best friend were
like already kind of like mingling
and then he just like drunkenly stumbled
up
so
it just yeah so your standards are
pretty high then all right
it's about where i assume most straight
women that's not where it started i feel
like
like it
my friend went home with that guy and it
just kind of happened so so your friend
likes the other guy so you figured you'd
like this guy
i gave him a chance
how long have you all been together
sit seven years i think sets about going
on seven all right at the seven you're
it she's pimping you out to other dates
that's nice i know he's signing you up
he got so mad that i didn't go out the
first time so he's like
go up there what's up here i am did do
you want to be in an open relationship
no
it's exhausting it sounds don't knock it
till you try it uh
i don't know
if he does i've never asked him
caius
have you ever been in an open
relationship
not by choice
but you said don't knock it till you try
it right does that mean she was cheating
on you what do you mean
yeah okay
yeah
did you knock it when you try surprise i
i took the fall for it because i never
clarified whether it was exclusive so
when i found out i was like
i can't be that mad and i was also
cheating on her so it was fine wait so
you you call it you just said you didn't
know the rules and yet you said you were
cheating on her yeah it's different if
you're a dude
you what
it's different yeah i don't like people
from new hampshire
we all now have a stereotype about new
hampshire
it's a hard no for me
i now don't let my views
um no it's actions cloud your judgment
of a beautiful state with great the
false house and i've hacked a mountain
in new hampshire before 13 miles of
coastline and amazing seafood say 13
miles 13 miles of coastline a good
number
it's amazing it sounds like a lake if
you compare it to massachusetts it's
amazing let's see we just called your
state of lake please please please visit
our great state
yeah
foolishness
you're not representing your state well
i don't know what to tell you can't sell
it now
you look like the
you look like you're in wall street
he's not [ __ ] leaving yeah he looks
like he's not [ __ ] leaving the
opposite of a non-profit job yeah that
was
what do you do for a living or would you
just not tell us
i'm building a medical product is it
that all of you want to buy he's selling
cocaine
that would be the most likable thing
about this guy
i'm i'm selling cocaine not laced with
fentanyl
that's a that's a there's a market for
that yeah
let's go
let's go let's bring back old cocoon
[Applause]
[Music]
rainy street in the house
i just revealed everything all my
secrets
you revealed nothing yeah we don't know
anything about you
so caius uh have you what's the longest
relationship that you've been in
okay i'm being totally honest right now
six years
with your mother
that's ongoing why would you not be
honest about that
six years is like a good you know yeah
yeah i don't know it seems like
something
well it seems like people want to lie
about a long relationship because they
want to say like hey i went to college
it's the same [ __ ] like i went to
college in four years so i'm not a piece
of [ __ ] so you're honestly six years
you're not
lying like you're not a douchebag
i am i i'm technically a douchebag
oh no yeah you know
you definitely know and you
don't know but you're good so what
happened to the six-year relationship
uh she she just got too old for me
i know i just i just sent it down the
[ __ ] river dude
like she's 22 it's too old for me
dude it was 19 19 to 25.
and you were like girl is way past her
prime
she started looking like her mom
started acting like her mom
how do you know her mom
her mom's still pretty hot
was hot and it's still hot then what's
the problem
because her mom was very mean to her
father i'm being honest this isn't on it
this is not comedy this is honest
her mom was very mean to her dad
and i said and i was like you're
starting to kind of act mean
and i and i said i said get the [ __ ] out
of my face maybe you deserved it
i didn't deserve it i'm a beautiful man
i'm a wonderful man well you did say
that she was i'm like
you were judging her based on her age
you didn't say her behavior was getting
worse she said her physical she rounded
up to 30 so you were done hans you know
what you're [ __ ] right man she was
just getting old
no she was she was she was uh she was
mean to you yeah but but but but this is
actually hilarious
she turned into a power lifter after i
stopped dating her so
when i met her she was 19
and she was a smoking hot stereotypical
blonde skinny trick so it's like you see
her on the street and you go oh like
yeah i'd probably rape her cool
oh my god like i would go to jail i
would i could take five minutes for the
new hampshire to come out i go to jail
for this girl
but then but then i dated her for six
years and
now she's a power lifter and she could
rape you she
she could rape me
i would like to watch that
we all want to see anything
does anyone not want to watch kaios get
raped at this point
[ __ ] me baby
jesus christ i'm sorry why did you say
that
that's horrible um i'm really just
saying that to you holmes
paige what are you
are you glad that you're off the market
like
what was what was your dating
what was your dating life like before
you met your wonderful
wonderful husband that signs you up for
things
uh i didn't really date for a couple
years before him because it was so bad
prior to it too many
too many
yeah that's exactly what it was nailed
it can someone at least beat kaios up
later
could we arrange that
it looks like paul dano if he [ __ ] you
look like uh who the [ __ ] is that paul
dano yeah
joseph gordon love it
if you were like he does come here i
know he's a he's a national treasure
yeah you look like him if he hated
musicals
or joseph gordon love it
uh if joseph gordon levitt were a rapist
you just said you'd rape
someone looked at a certain person it's
a figure of speech
[Laughter]
everybody wants to rape somebody
come on
everybody wants to rape somebody's going
out live on youtube
arrested
has just lost his job at his non-profit
teen homeless youth outreach
caius what do you do for work
you already asked me that
you never said it again
boring stuff man you only answer
honestly about rape
and everything else is a lie that's the
mean potatoes
yeah that's all we care about
that's scary
um
paige so uh what was the longest
relationship before your current husband
uh about a year probably a year wow i
wouldn't say it's pretty so this is like
a long term this is like the first time
that you've been in like a long term
thing with your husband
what is it that you liked about him
besides his upfront approach and lack of
that's about it no i'm just kidding uh
he's nice he's good he's nice he's funny
he's funny what's the funniest thing
he's done
um
so we have besides signing up for a date
with a rapist
that is so true
that's rude yeah
um i'm not a rapist just in case
anybody's wondering you already admitted
it
he wanted to rape her
he just dated her for six years and
abandoned her because she was 25.
you said it not us
that was 25 year olds they might as well
be 40.
[Laughter]
they're way too old for caius
but wait you were going to tell us the
story of something funny oh it's not
really that funny though like it's like
one of those things that i think is
funny because
i love myself i think it'll tell us more
about him and you and i think it might
be sweet
i think i think
as long as it's better than rape yeah
yeah
uh so
he's he's looking at me like he's
nervous um
we have three dogs and we don't have
kids and so
like
he makes voices for our dogs
and i think that's funny
[Laughter]
luckily it's not come up
that's that's really cute we raised our
dogs better than that yeah
unlike his mom yeah you don't raise your
dogs like they're in new hampshire right
right right
should we get guys a different date
anything controversial you want to say
right now
like uh my ultra maga or like what are
you trying to do
he's up to date on the latest i don't
know man
nailed it you know what i'm always
wondering i'll say something
controversial whether the police are
gonna come in and arrest you no nobody
nobody nobody's coming for me i'm clean
as a whistle
no std i'm allowed to carry a lot of
carry guns
oh yeah and not yeah yeah no i'm one of
those texas people that i'm because it's
new hampshire
a rapist are you ready
are you ready yeah
uh no i think um i will say something
controversial
and also maybe meaningful
but
is that funny that's funny yeah
that's my husband taking a while i think
that people in
austin can't wait can be whoever they
want to be
but i but i think if you come to austin
yeah if you've lived in austin for 30
years or if you come to austin
last week
you need to speak you need you just need
to keep an open mind
and you need to be willing to accept
ultimately stick in your ass and
you need to be totally willing to like
suck some like nasty ass homeless dick
or don't give it up page you want to go
on a date with a real human being with a
soul
good to see you okay
yes you can get your drink real quick
paige
give it up for paige a real woman
she's a soldier
she had to deal with
caius
i feel dirty after i didn't shake his
hand yeah i
and then he hit my he fistbucked me very
hard i guess that was his way again i'm
like i just i don't want to shake the
hand of a man who said i thought about
raping a 19 year old blonde chick
fist bumped you really hard i think
that's domestic abuse
demetrius
oh his friend
[Music]
demetrius
i don't know is a friend of mine tag
teaming things
let's get another person up here
not from that table hopefully
jake gonzalez
okay
let's hear it from jake
[Music]
[Applause]
he's got wacky voices
jake gonzalez and
paige wilson going on a date starting
now i haven't changed my last name yet
hey sexy
what what what's your number
seven
seven
i'm gay
you wanna [ __ ] tonight or what
you off your period
[Music]
i'll take that as a yes
we're [ __ ]
i don't even know
all right well
our dogs would be disappointed in you
right now
not if there was peanut butter involved
talk like that jake
creamy
just please stop this
and time my god get up for jake gonzalez
paige wilson
what made you fall in love with jake it
wasn't his with
just look at him says way with words
yeah
i don't even not like that guy
no he's not no
no do y'all not have period sex is that
off the table
[Applause]
[Laughter]
so
you're pretty bold you know you just go
up to girls and marry them
yes what uh what was your dating life
like
before that
i wasn't dating
like girlfriend boyfriend you're a
celibate
no i wouldn't say that but
uh
let's get you in trouble tonight i know
i think you could [ __ ]
i don't know
it was normal i would say it's normal
normal
wow this is the best this is like the
most handsome autistic guy i've ever met
do you work in tech
no i don't
uh so you just
waste your autistic talents
yes
what uh what do you do
uh air duct cleaning
air duct cleaning yes how did you get
into that uh my father-in-law
her dad he decided to start a business
and was like i need some help and i was
like all right i'll help you
and uh now i can't breathe that good so
yeah
but at least the air ducts are clean so
your phone does it at casinos so it's
like really bad your father-in-law is
trying to kill you
yeah i guess slowly yes
[Music]
yeah what's your number the number of
years you're going to be alive
[Laughter]
so you guys are a beautiful couple um
how old are you guys
30. oh too late
that's five years back
luckily i'm past that guy's prime yeah
i'm 30 also nice
is there anything that you like to say
to kais maybe to lead him on the correct
path
maybe help him get a girlfriend and a
wife
if you do rape a girl make sure there's
no witnesses
what jake
leave him
oh my god
i wasn't done yet and i wasn't done
um
so you're an advocate of the bill cosby
method no i was just
if you do do it make sure there's no
witness is all i'm saying yeah you don't
want to traumatize more people yeah
exactly yeah i'm not saying you should
do it
but if you do
you know yeah if you do do it you know
be smart about it don't be an idiot this
is the oh
you should leave him
that sucks
he's just being goofy
that's not that what is the goofiest
rape joke that jake has made
i
that's probably it
unless i have not heard one before that
so
do you uh what do you guys like to do
together work out
comedy and that's that's like watch
movies yeah [ __ ] like that with movie
nerds watch comedy comedy nerds do you
guys ever do can you guys reenact your
favorite movie scene
no because it's hereditary he would be
in that
bear
what hereditary or i mean uh
mid-summer
it's summer oh we're planning our
halloween costume right now and it's
gonna be that
he's getting embarrassed it's hereditary
the one where that's the gross one yeah
i got
there like the little kid gets hit by a
pole
yes yeah
that was the wrong one i got we were
just talking about that earlier i meant
mid-summer mid-summer yeah that's your
favorite i feel like that one he loves
super a lot this summer is the one where
they go to like sweden and then they get
systematically
murdered by this cult he's into that
that's what new hampshire is like yeah
exactly
13 miles of coastline for us to
drag your body through
where are you guys from oklahoma
oh [ __ ] we saw you guys
oh yeah
yeah
that's crazy yeah look at us all yeah
let's all together again just chilling
[Music]
so what what are you guys doing here in
austin
kill tony
hell yeah
that's a barbecue
and this show right yeah oh no it's it
was definitely this show is what brought
us here yeah thank you yeah
[Music]
we appreciate it yeah it's a good show
so jake um
what do you think about being bisexual
would you ever
uh i want to kill myself
because of that
because you are bisexual you want to
kill yourself because uh
i don't want people to know
so you are a little bisexual
depends you know
this guy is definitely a kill tony fan
they're all sort of bisexual yeah i mean
i got a prize you know
what's your price a million dollars
no one's paying for that no i know and
that's why i want to kill myself
okay
paige what's the funniest voice that
your husband has done
do josie's voice
y'all want me to do my dog's voice it's
my dog's voice
with sister songs no jake gonzalez
sound like a male voice sounding like a
dog go
hey dada
i'm hungry can i have some food please
that's it
um i love you
that's that's josie yeah
that sounded like caius's 19 year old
girlfriend
i'm sorry i know i suck
i'm trying
i said it was cute for us not for
everyone
uh
uh what's jake
so what is something that paige does
that you find very very endearing
endearing
[Music]
[ __ ] you
that's cool
um
she came to austin and agreed to let me
sign her up for this i did not agree to
this
i raped her into this
another rapist on stage all right all
right
at least that was actually the funniest
thing he said this whole
time
at least he didn't say the n-word
yeah that's true
that'd be an issue
so you guys met at a bar
he asked for your number
and then what happened
she said i asked his name
and then i said
and he was like i don't care just give
me your number
no
we said or i told him that he'd have to
get to know me to get my number and then
my friend went home with his friend so
i had to babysit her so i naturally went
there so
we just hung out and
you had a friend i ended up getting my
number after we talked the night so he
ended up being a cool guy you talked all
night yeah
fun yeah
[Music]
no that's that's cool so like uh
yeah you were like give me your number
and she's like
my name is paige
and i was like yeah no no anyways uh
you ready to leave
so you're
like a good strategy
would be to have a friend that gets
laid pretty pretty well and then just be
a friend to him and then you'll get
married yeah it worked out they take
ownership in it so are they still
together
no
no they were great like
friends with benefits for a bit but
uh yeah no but they
my friend still takes credit for it
saying thank goodness that she does one
night stand so
at least someone's getting
long-term happiness as your friend is
crying into her martini
what a what a beautiful success story of
a heterosexual
pretty white couple yeah this is what
straight couples i know i am so sorry
i wish i was funnier but i just don't
have it in me
you have any words of advice for this uh
vanilla couple
oh me
i do y'all have hobbies together that
you do
hobbies like what do you mean like
together like that we do stuff that you
do together but i mean besides dating
other people on weird comedy shows
we really we watch
we watch a lot of comedy together um we
watch tv shows like we're not like big
like going out people so it's just like
the home stuff with our dogs and hanging
out with family so i mean like we're
pretty boring i'm so sorry our hobbies
i think they're right for each other so
that's so kind that is the kindest diss
anyone's ever given and i'm okay with it
thank you give it up for jake and paige
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you they are married
another people dating show success story
yay yes i'm taking credit for this one
that was a show what did you think about
all the people that we had on yikes your
audience is [ __ ] up dude
caius
we love you bro
we don't we don't don't rape anyone
tonight please don't
uh but yeah we had the uh homeless the
guy that [ __ ] homeless guys we had the
girl that said the n-word and then two
rape joke people yeah
that's pretty much the show in a
nutshell
uh you have any dates or any shows or
podcasts
uh yeah i'm gonna do the show here at
eight o'clock the it's a gay competition
show
on tuesday i'm featuring for louis ck
here but it's sold out so that's great
yeah
and uh here we're going for ariel isaac
norman
you can find her at uh instagram uh
ellen degeneres yeah yeah i also have a
podcast uh check out the gender fluids
podcast it's me and this trans chick
talking about sex gender and kink
make sure to bring your alcohol swabs
yeah
cool well that was the show thank you so
much good night
[Applause]
[Music]